boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Saki and
we are on site in B in Boston
Massachusetts in Cambridge we are at MIT
Massachusetts Institute of Technology we
are sitting down with Dr Woody flowers
hello good to see you thank you for
coming on to the show Welcome to MIT I
love being at MIT and I also love being
with you this is I'm really excited for
our interview um okay so background on
Woody Woody for the last 45 years has
been here at MIT doing mechanical
engineering professing he's a papardo uh
Emeritus professor of mechanical
engineering here that's right and lots
of uh inspiring students here to to
build the future and also uh co-founder
of first robotics which is inspiring
millions of of kids around the world uh
to mechanically electrically computation
design and engineer robots to complete
objectives on playing fields building
teamwork skills all this kind of stuff
we've talked about first a lot on our on
our show and Woody's background has so
many other epic things um he is a a
co-founder of a company called Med
minder and there's a bunch of other cool
things in there with an um with the
National Academy of engineering uh
member there there's it will take me too
long to list all of Woody's epic
accomplishments over the years and I'm
really excited to be doing this to be
doing this interview on site um Woody I
really want to start uh by talking to
you also can't forget about the um 2017
Vex robotic stem Hall of Fame uh there's
so much cool stuff in here um okay let's
start talking to you about your um the
your love for mechanical engineering so
when you you were young when did you
figure out that you loved mechanical
engineering and why did you fall in love
with
it I couldn't get a date so I had to
resort to mechanical
engineering
um I was very
lucky my growing up was a very
multifaceted thing for me
um grew up in a small town in Louisiana
Gina
Louisiana um Gina was known
for unfortunately mostly unfortunate
things like the riots that were
associated with the genus 6 and stuff
there was um being black in Gina was not
easy and uh
so I was very lucky to have to live in a
family where we did not think that way
and we were dirt
poor and but there was a lot of love in
the family my my
sister worshiped learning and Athletics
and I was the little brother that had a
lot to live up to and um in my junior
year or so we didn't have a car so I
couldn't date so my uncle gave me a
1947 Dodge four-door sedan a big ugly
thing that I drove home holding both
hands on one side of the steering wheel
because if I turn loose it would go
straight into the
ditch so I told my dad that I wanted to
make a hot rod out of it and
characteristic of Dad's manner he looked
at me for a bit and said well okay
scooter but if you start it you got to
finish it so building a hot rod was uh
my introduction to mechanical
engineering and my father was an
interesting man in that he uh was a
wonderful inventor and Builder and a
creative thinker terrible
businessman but he's a welder so we had
a welding shop and U you know Dad would
he didn't have a peer review committee
so he would go around town saying I'm
going to take a Frets and a widget and
put them together and make a thing of a
jig and everybody' say Abe you crazy son
of a you can't do that and he
would say well okay and then he would do
it and come back and say see and that
was the way he rewarded himself for
thinking outside the box I think I
probably emulated that because that
probably gave me some freedom but in the
last part of my senior
year uh my social studies teacher
noticed that I couldn't fully extend my
left arm I had fallen out of the
p in second grade
and exactly set well so
but the Sy said Rehabilitation sent me
to a hospital 40 mil away I'm an nor
Peak surgeon looked at me and said you
need Rehabilitation road to the state so
I got a rehabilitation scholarship in
the last part of my senior year and
everybody said that's an opportunity you
can't turn down which foiled my plan to
get a job in the oilfield and buy a
Corvette they have a cool car so went
off to college and I knew I wasn't
prepared I had to take algebra and trig
in college because I didn't have a good
background at all so I I was afraid that
I was not going to make it so I worked
really
hard and then I finished my freshman
year and um then I went off to Louisiana
Tech engineering school and everybody
said well you know that's that's hard
you have to really work hard so again I
felt insecure enough that I worked
really hard and that sort of stuff kept
happening I was U about to graduate and
my friends were getting job offers from
the oil field for $750 a month and I
thought wow that's amazing I can I can
help Mom and Dad pay off debts and I can
get some clothes and I can get that
Corvette that I've been waiting for and
my department head called me in and said
have you applied to graduate school I
said what he said you should and I did
and then I got admitted to MIT and
everybody said that's opportunity you
can't turn down Etc then same thing
happened with joining the faculty and
during that process I I had met Margaret
and we uh we got married just at the
transition from her ending her master's
degree at Louisiana Tech and me um
trying to get into the PHD program here
yeah and a lot changed
yeah starting off with uh the hot rod
and wanting to you know you got to you
got to finish the project that you want
to start and that you had um a father
that was an an inspiring figure for you
that helped you see how to how to how to
see limit to get through limiting
beliefs and my mother was a role model
for thinking carefully about other
people tell us a bit about that well
just that um I you know my sister was
Val Victorian of everything she's ever
been in uh quite literally even her
college class and ended up being a ghost
writer for Senator elander when he was
the senior senator in DC and
um the two of us did not end up with
some of the racism that inflicted the
rest of the community and neither one of
us can precisely identify what part of
the life at home helped us reach that
conclusion but Mom and Dad but primarily
probably mom with philosophy was the big
influence and U yeah so I I thank her
for that and I thank dad for encouraging
me
to do things that seemed like the right
thing to do
and now you you went through the process
of working really hard and getting into
MIT going through this process you spent
you you did your Masters and your PhD
here and this is go back to that just
for a moment but you know I think it's
reasonable to argue that I'm a great
argument for how impostor syndrome can
be a positive thing because if you
always feel like you're surrounded by
people that are more qualified than you
MH then you're probably going to try
hard and that's certainly been the case
for me I have liter I mean I don't have
any doubt about the fact that in my
career I've been lucky enough to be
surrounded by really smart people yes
and that's intimidating and intimidation
can be helpful yes if it doesn't beat
you down yeah so I I've told many
students to make friends with a knot in
your stomach yeah because if you
recognize it as a stimulate stimulant
rather than something that you run from
then it can be helpful but if it shuts
you down that's not going to
help and this is actually this is a
perfect
um so I can actually I to to tie into
this point that that Woody's bringing up
right now so so you know Woody has these
all different types and you can see this
in in in in here Woody has so many
different mechanical engineering designs
that that help with uh with the process
of of of of of engineering and so this
is when Woody says you know sit around
sit across from people pass time with
people that have a greater intelligence
than you do across different disciplines
and learn from them and really uh make
that a key principle of what you do
surround yourself with very smart people
what immediately when I came in here
started pointing out all of these
different engineering uh gadgets that he
has in here that are designs for how to
um how to how to make uh products and
services um much uh more effectively
into our world um Woody what is this one
again that's a Smith coupling and it's
coupling it's good for transferring
rotary motion from one to the other when
the shafts are not align and you know it
does kind of counterintuitive things it
behaves in an odd way but you one can't
be creative about devices unless you
have a vocabulary of stuff you you know
a uniquely human characteristic that's
really important is making loose
analogies and jumping from one venue to
another yeah Crossing metaphors and
things like that so getting curious
about stuff is a fundamental part of
growth yes yes and so I'm I'm glad that
you brought that up um it's a key
principle with what we do and who we sit
down with um and uh constantly aiming to
um make ourselves more comfortable with
the uncomfortable and then um uh keep
surrounding ourselves with people that
we can learn from uh on a on a on a
transgenerational wisdom dissemination
basis and and growth now I want to I
want to talk about this you ended up P
you kind you you ended up pioneering a
really popular course here um you this
was a you did it for 13 years and it was
it was this uh it was a it was the
course that was uh that was it was what
was it called design and Engineering um
actually it went through some name
changes but I think introduction to
design yeah introduction to design was
the one that settled on after a while it
was design and Manufacturing one I think
maybe when we first started but uh you
know I don't remember exactly 270
2.70 was the MIT language for the course
the students never used a name name for
2.70 yeah and then this and now it's
two7 by two7 yep it changed and then so
this was from uh
1974 to
1987 yeah actually I started working
with the
course probably in 1968 yes yes so as a
graduate student I was a student
instructor yes a student instructor of
course and then um to the professing
side a couple about five years later or
so and then so so what this is very
interesting and I think this is really
important to talk about because this is
kind of a lot of the mentality that you
bring into first robotics um but so now
now teach us about the this course this
introduction design course because you
had students solve a complex challenge
with robotic engineering so yeah teach
us about this
well when I was a student I had a very
poor academic background but I had used
a a hammer and bent metal and I had made
things I had done a lot of engineering
and learned a lot of engineering from my
father although my father was only a
high school graduate
he so when I was studying mechanics and
people were teaching us about poon's
ratio that meant something physical to
me and I think I believe it's
complicated topic and I don't want to
oversimplify
but we learn engineering
principles altogether too often by going
to the symbolic manipulation
mathematical language and saying this is
the explanation and then coming back and
say see what that means about the
physical
world I had an advantage because I had
the physical Insight because I'd done it
not because I was smart or anything but
it was just part of my background so the
stuff that we were doing in symbolic
manipulation meant something it was more
believable it was more
tangible some of the kids that came from
much more uh Advanced High School
backgrounds hadn't done that and they
were left with
with they may have made a 100 on the
test and knew how to do the symbolic
manipulation but they may not have known
how to use that to
estimate model think about so
here um when I was first involved in the
270 course the department head the
person who became the department head
later wonderful man named her Richardson
um had heard about a thing called a
create creativity kit that I think Xerox
maybe had done at Xerox Park so we gave
the students a creativity kit and said
make something useful the creativity kit
was a bunch of paper clips and rubber
bands and things of that
sort and my officemate and I were both
teaching sections of the course and we
watched our students really struggle
with what am I going to make that's a
big hard problem mhm that's one of the
most sophisticated things a designer
ever does is decide what to design
interes so and you have to dedicate
their time they would flounder flounder
flounder and finally the night before
try to make something interesting so my
office mate and I don Margolis and I
said next year let's give them the
problem and oh oh instead of just from
yeah let's let's say this is the problem
build something to do this design and
build something to do this and we did
that and that was the Genesis of you
know the the competition and the first
year we did it I built one
myself
and that was I had a key to the student
shop so I could go
in I could go in at night so I went in
the night before
and the thing was to build a machine
that would essentially move continuously
down a ramp 30° ramp okay in as near 3
minutes as possible okay so I made a
clock everybody made clocks without
realizing they were making clocks but
you so as the wheels moved rotated this
escapement operated through this
torsional pendulum to move down the hill
and this was the tuning to change the
natural frequency of this Pendulum by
moving the weights in and out okay and
it worked and I was very happy it was
hard to do because I made the the
escapement by filing part of a gear that
was in the kit and in order to make the
escapement work I had to drill a hole
down the middle of one of the paperclip
wires to make a little roller bearing to
operate the
escapement and after the students did
their competition I put mine down and it
just slid down the ramp because there
had been sand in the kit and sand was on
the ramp it wasn't on the ramp when I
tested the night before so it didn't
stick and that was the best outcome that
we could have hoped for because that was
exactly what uh you know the the the
instructor got snared by an unexpected
thing too
so that was it seemed to work you know
the students got a lot of insight out of
it
um and
the next year we learned a
lot and we started learning that there
were if you would like to have someone
learn about themselves learn that they
can be creative then you really don't
want to give them the wrong kind of
exercise after we became fairly well
known for doing this stuff I'd have
faculty from other places come up and
say well I had this I had this
consulting job that I couldn't do so I
gave it to the students as a creative
exercise and I'd want to punch them out
it's a terrible thing to do I mean if
you couldn't do it why the why would you
take this precious opportunity and teach
somebody that creativity won't solve a
problem so a good creative exercise must
be
possible must be possible in many ways
everyone succeeds but a gradation of
success a whole bunch of them must not
have a killer complex obvious answer
that everybody tries to get through and
can't make work youd have gradations of
value in different ways to do it so
thinking carefully about how you
structure a creative exercise is
important yes
and true
education is not about consuming
codified material I hope we'll come back
and talk more about that but true
education has to do with helping someone
come to know helping someone develop a
self that allows them to know from
personal experience that they can do
something that is creative or new or
hard Etc so you make that list of
different things you'd like for them to
know about themselves but the most
important transcript is not what's
written in the registar office on a
computer file it's what a person knows
about themselves and I think you know I
think universities should get out of the
business of keeping transcripts there
should be a blockchain account that you
own that you can let somebody look at
but anyway that's a a different branch
things that you've potentially created
well and that that's that's the stuff
that you really want to if I were going
to ask you for a job correct I should be
able to say to you here you can look all
the way to the bottom of my record yes
and see what you want or I could let you
see you can learn all the exercises that
I had completed in this software package
yes correct or whatever correct from all
the way through all the different um
mechanical
you and keep a log of all the interviews
that I've done so these are the ways to
potentially grade an analyze and then
you also made this really interesting
point about gradients in the creative
process and and making sure that a
challenge is going to be leading
students um to something that they
better understand themselves that they
better understand how uh engineering
actually works Works to solve important
challenges there's like you said
gradients of success uh along that along
the way there's a bunch of different
ways to solve it this is all extremely
important and it also has made it so
that the the students that have been
taking your course um as well as now are
going through the process within first
robotics are are solving some really
pressing challenges while learning a
tremendous amount about strategy that
they can use that are applicable across
a wide array of of engineering design
tasks yeah the the njk comment is you're
not going to get a job solving the
problems at the end of the
chapter so you know that's that's not
what you're preparing yourself to do and
uh the other axis of that process
was so spend a long tale about how 270
became well known while I was helping
with the course and another faculty
member were was in charge of it while I
was still a graduate student uh we saw
the local news media come in and the
video crew would kind of interrupt the
process and be a little overbearing and
then that night on the Evening News the
two co-anchors would chuckle knowingly
and say things like well what are those
nerds at MIT doing now and it was all an
incredibly worthless condescending
statement about what the students were
doing despite the fact that there was
some really solid pedagogy yeah being
done yeah so I told the news office when
I became in charge just don't tell
anybody we're doing it so for quite a
few years we we were stealth yeah and
then the folks from discover the world
of science came and said we'd like to do
a program about uh the competition and
during that time was that PBS uh it was
it was aired on
PBS
um bester cram and Steve Asher had done
a
16mm film documentary about one of the
years and it was very well done it was a
30 minute thing and it you know except
for the effort that we went do to clean
up the students
language it in a time when things were
in turmoil and the the halls of MIT were
painted with lots of stuff and very
interesting time but um so it was very
clear that if you watch that video there
was some serious stuff happening
and uh we uh so they came and said we'd
like to do it and I said no thank you
and the producer went away and later the
owners of the company came back and said
we'd like to take you to lunch and we'd
like to talk about this so I explained
what was going on and they said look
we're talking about a 16 minute or so
piece that would be aired and we're
serious about this and Etc and I said
okay write a letter to the students and
I'll ask them if they want to do
it and so they did and the students said
yes let's do it during that
time I told the students
that when you're doing this stuff
imagine that your grandmother is going
to watch everything that you do as part
of a nationalized television
documentary and see how that feels and
they did that so well I mean it's just
amazing it was sort of I was expressing
what they were already doing but I
started calling that gracious
professionalism because it was compete
like crazy yeah which am absolutely yeah
students will do but treat each other
kindly and in the process and they took
great pride in teaching everybody else
what they were learning so that spirit
is so much more important than lots of
other things that could have happened
and that was
um it's a wonderful thing to watch
happen come beat like crazy and and be
kind and cooperative and teach other
people what you're learning help each
other that's a that gracious
professionalism has now uh been going on
for 30 years with first robotics now but
even prior to that was a big principle
of MIT um with your work here that's so
cool um you you had also this is this is
actually a really important point this
is obviously a a v a video show and when
you bring up news anchors and short
sound bited segments laughing at the
Nerds at MIT we're so beyond that and
I'm really excited that we're beyond
that with capturing conversations like
what we're aiming to do here right now
um we're moving away from these sound
bited sort of uh click baity um Echo
chambery type things where we're not
paying respect to the Science and
Technology leaders that are actually
building the uh automation processes
that are solving some of the pressing
challenges and uh increasing the
standard of living for humans around the
world so um I think we're evolving to gr
more better understand the importance of
of what's actually happening within the
doors of of MIT as well as within the um
classrooms of students that are in stem
around the world so that actually that
sort of um design process for for for
students that was here as at at MIT um
in in your course is actually now
carried into first robotics and I guess
prior to getting to to first robotics
can we let's talk quickly about um your
professing here at MIT I want to know
what have been some of the most profound
takeaways as a teacher and Professor to
thousands of
students well
um I
don't I don't like to think of myself as
a
teacher uh I like to think of myself as
someone who's tries to create an
opportunity for someone to learn about
themselves so orchestrated
doing is U is a better model I think so
let me morph that somewhat into my
thought about what we need to do about
the education
system
um
being a young person now if you're
paying attention it's very daunting
because by midcareer if you make a
reasonable projection of what's going to
happen things are going to be very
different and yeah the number of things
that so you know at the first
kickoff this last weekend I gave a
little pitch that said Dean talks about
first being being the hardest fun you've
ever had so fun gets lumped together
into groups and it becomes joy and joy
evolves into Happiness and happiness if
expands well ends up being satisfaction
and satisfaction together can end up
being a meaningful life and in the first
context I said if you do all that in as
a gracious professional it all works
well that hierarchy is is really very
important
um you have to know enough to think well
about what you're trying to do you have
to be able to make a deal with society
that says I give you this if you give me
back need me and love me and those are
the really high value
pieces getting to that point is getting
to be tougher
most of what I you know over there on
that wall is a whole bunch of homework
files that are still left over from
graduate school for for example you
know almost everything that's in those
books is now reduced to one keystroke on
a program
do what is it that students are learning
now that will still be good barter
material with Society in midcareer what
uniquely human things will still be
uniquely human some years from
now I worry about uh of all Noah
hari's use of the term useless class
because we humans don't do well when we
feel useless we start misbehaving in
very destructive ways yeah so I have
told the the first kid for a long time
now that you're going to be successful
because you're doing the right stuff
you're working really hard to learn
everything you can and you have the
right attitude about how you fit with
Society you are gracious
professional but if you want to be
successful in a life in a place that
you'd like to be in every one of you has
to figure out a way to pull at least a
hundred others with you yeah and boy is
that hard that's really complicated yeah
and some may be able to do it by curing
cancer or you know making major
breakthrough but there's a whole bunch
of activities that we still need to
upgrade so that they make sense
so I I see the whole education system
has a big problem and my proposal is
relatively simple I think is that we
must recognize that training and
education are different they do overlap
but learning calculus is training
learning to think using calculus is
education learning a CAD program is
training learning to design is education
learning a coding language is training
learning to be an efficient reasonable
programmer is education learning the
algorithmic thinking there's a whole
bunch of things that parse that
way I am absolutely convinced that an AI
augmented digital system will be a
better
trainer than human because it'll be
adaptive it can be one-onone it has
broad broader bandwidth than you ever do
we can democratize we can make that
available to very large number of people
and we may have to do that by having the
people that can pay pay and the people
that can't pay not but you we have to do
it well has to be really so export
training to
Machin Focus residential programs or in
school programs in particular on on
stuff that requires presence you know we
can't afford to use presence our most
valuable asset to do training so that
means that when you get people
together from the teachers which I put
in
quotes and peers you learn about
yourself and if you develop a self-image
that includes knowing from personal
experience that you can do something
difficult do something creative do
something ethically complex do something
unpopular do something with others for
others
Etc then you're making a lot of progress
and at many times during a career you
must be able to reach over into
your now well-informed self about how
you train yourself if you needed to go
learn
thermodynamics Do It Go learn the
codified part of thermodynamics come
back and let's talk about how we're
going to use that understanding to do a
new heat
transfer solution to solar panels that
are so efficient that are you know Etc
there's a couple things that you brought
up there that are so crucial um the
first one that you brought up was the
fact that this word teacher is actually
more about enabling new minds birthed
into the world to to have their
perspective be augmented to to see the
world in new interesting lenses and ways
and
um and then have them go through
processes of tinkering and actually
Hands-On learning where that knowledge
becomes um ingrained and then they can
go and teach others and go and build
with it that was really interesting and
I think that's extremely important then
you also again this second part is kind
of like that you said you got to bring a
hundred people with you to this new way
of seeing reality so that if you do
potentially uncover something really
interesting that you can that a
challenge that you can solve you said
cancer that's you know biotch maybe it's
something related to the space economy
or new protocol for programming a
blockchain something like that that you
pull more uh more young people with you
to see the world in that in that way and
potentially build that with you they
build their own after they learn so
that's a really important Point um and
then there was another um Point well it
kind of leads into this this um this
last this well the transition into into
first a little bit here but um it seems
as though that this this essence of of
of the importance of of uh of of
Education versus training I I want to
actually talk about that um later with
Automation and and AI um because that
let's go to first and then we'll get
there because
um so for so so this this this prepar
ation of Youth as young as 6 years old
to start tinkering with building and
designing and Engineering um in Legos to
start um and and there's still even some
block-based programming uh involved like
component based programming which is
very interesting um for young so as long
as young as six as old as as 18 are are
designing and Engineering role robots to
complete objectives on playing fields uh
half a million kids a year 80 countries
100 countries now 100 countries 60,000
teams um and there's you know 50,000
robots that are actually um being
engineered and designed to complete
these objectives and like this year's
theme is space everything space related
and again this is what's what's going on
we're going to the space economy so the
kids are learning how to complete these
objectives to get used to um the to
space economy so um and they're not just
designing engineering they're learning
about the emotional skills the emotional
intelligences of teamwork gracious
professionalism um they're also learning
about how to make business plans and
fundraise and be entrepreneurs in that
sense and and um work with mentors and
coaches so this is all building youth
for the future and that's why I've been
um uh judging and and mcing and game
announcing and loving being uh a part of
the ecosystem first for the last three
plus years now so teach Woody thank you
I I'm I there's there's 30 there 30
years with first now and there's been
lots of um volunteers that I've met that
have been involved for decades in Crazy
cool um okay so teach us so teach us
about what the you know this what we're
going through with this transition with
this Education and Training and how
first is actually getting us ready for
that well um
this will sound arrogant but I don't
think it is necessarily I think first is
a reasonable model for what the
education system needs to become
absolutely because there's a whole bunch
of features to First that are much more
representative and I'll take a somewhat
controversial position by
saying stem is so
yesterday even steam is so yesterday we
have to be over the Horizons The Uber
stem whatever you want however you want
to say it but most
of the education system's effort in stem
is actually Math and Science
training that's really important but
it's not enough that other stuff is much
more likely to be the uniquely human
stuff that enables one
to intersect with Society in a way that
makes you have a meaningful life
so first happens to be the mix that you
talked about and
um I worry that first is so big now that
getting a very large number of people to
embrace gracious professionalism and uh
the ethos of first that started a long
time
ago we don't want that to get out of
hand and also first needs to keep up you
know we
if you look at the first web pages and
stuff there's still the term stem is in
there a whole
bunch we have to make sure people
understand that it's more than stem yes
it's not just stem and the kids in first
do what I just described in the sense
that they oh I don't know how to do this
I'll go to the
digital wealth pile and find it and
learn how to do it and come back and
apply to this problem yeah it's it's
really
interesting so they're they're taking
the a scary part away from a lot of
things you know when I
was in college uh PID control
proportional integral differential
control was an exotic thing that you
encountered in a graduate course high
school kids know what that is now you
high school high school kids are doing
stress anal is that's way more
sophisticated than I was able to do with
Cy gano's principal on a whole bunch of
hairy stuff years they do that in yeah
yeah I mean it's it's built in keystroke
done so if I mean Woody's talking shells
of of stuff that is now automated to
that's so
mindblowing and in in the way that that
it's very just quickly it's so
interesting how the Baseline of of that
wealth of knowledge has now went up so
high and democratized to make it so much
easier yeah and so interesting the you
know what that means is well me
um that's good news and that it brings
with it an ethical problem that we need
to be very careful about let's imagine
that you have a black box that can do
incredible stress analysis so you put a
bunch of stuff into it and the Black Box
does something and you get a result and
you build it and it falls apart and that
this all together too many examples of
that happening can't forget to make the
Black Box how to make it well if you
can't see what's going on I mean even if
you write a Exel spreadsheet yourself
you have to know roughly what the answer
is before you do that so
estimation is an incredibly important
uniquely human skill that's still going
to be relevant for a very long long time
and we we need to do that more overtly
and one of the things that first
does last couple years one of my main
messages to the first participants is
being right does not make you persuasive
and being persuasive does not make you
right and a uniquely human thing that we
must learn to do is recognize truth and
if you are in a team and there is a
beautiful person who is very eloquent
that has bad ideas and is very
persuasive boy they can wreck the team
yeah because they can lead the team down
bad and there may be a person that's
very quiet and never speaks up but has
really good stuff so you better learn
dig that out yes so you're going to hear
one of the things we learned in the in
the senior design course some years ago
we were having students do these
lightning pitches about various
ideas and they would do a used car sales
rather than discuss a design they
would say this is the best the most this
will solve all no no you're you're
trying to get your colleagues to pick
the right thing to do exaggerating
everything about it serves no function
whatsoever but that was culturally wired
in I mean you have to really beat on
that to get rid of it so we have to
learn you know right now with deep fake
and fake app and all the stuff that's
happening long time ago it became more
difficult you couldn't necessarily read
read believe what you read now you can't
believe what you see or hear or see yeah
yeah so being a sophisticated consumer
yeah is much more complicated and it
involves a whole bunch of stuff for
which there is no formula critically
thinking requires deep Nuance drive for
nuance and multiv variability and
empathy perspective taking all this type
of stuff to be able to build a complex
understanding of reality that's not in
an echo chamber binary sort of mentality
um and I think um in many ways like you
really we started pointing at this this
flow that that first robotics is not
only way more than just robots and um um
and stem but but also it's sort of an in
a in a way it's an ideal model for an
education system where youth from
starting the age of six are not only
doing the engineering and design skills
but then they're also learning the
emotional intelligence skills the pra
practicality of Business and
Entrepreneurship all
simultaneously um while being gracious
across countries across country lines so
there's a geopolitical um aspect to this
as well that they get to meet kids from
around the world and know that hey we're
both human we're looking for the same
things family health happiness
prosperity to um and so that's also been
something so interesting it's been
profound seeing um 6 to8 18-year-old
girls especially being able to pick up
the fact that they love the stem and
that they love uh the process of of of
working together and building things
into the world reinforce that in just a
minute one of my favorite videos is of a
group of
four kindergarten girls in the White
House with Obama and he walks up and
says what are you doing and they
show their Lego based robot that turns
Pages for people who can't turn pages by
themselves and in the conversation he
makes a comment about U how did you come
up with this idea and they say well we
had a brainstorming session and then
later he says well can you change the
adjustability of it and and they said oh
it's just a prototype so when you have
kindergarten girls yeah yeah saying
prototype and brainstorming we're making
progress great that's great and you you
don't you know that demystifies the
stuff you know you can bring those
things down to places in the culture
where they're incredibly more important
and they make cool they make engineering
notebooks to show how they got to the
designs engineer there's a lot to to
talk about um with first robotics can I
I want I want to bring this up um with
you Woody because I've brought this up
so many times with first at its at its
headquarter level and I've been trying
to get this to happen more I want more
entrepreneurship in first robotics I
think it's really tough because you
can't just take high school kids um and
and and because they they're on they're
on tracks to need to go to to colleges
and and all this other kind of stuff so
it's hard to to to pull them to pull
them aside to become entrepreneurs in a
in a sense but um it would be what would
you say would be the ideal way to
incorporate entrepreneurship more
effectively into first robotics to maybe
where kids that are 17 can actually
start executing the ideas that they have
as products into the world at 17 and
getting them out there and maybe they
want to start those companies and not
potentially right away go to the
workforce uh or college so what would
you well my my response would be kind of
complex um in about
1974 or five uh
with Francis Lee we offered the first
entrepreneurship course in the School of
Engineering at
MIT and in that same year or one year
later with Dave Jansen we offered the
first product design course in School of
Engineering at
MIT
um I have a lot of respect for the
intellectual complexity and
sophistication of that
and to make learning entrepreneurship as
real as possible one need needs to come
as close as possible to really doing it
yeah and that's hard and I know there
are examples of where people do say the
project is you're going to start a
company and at the end of the semester
we're going to have a profit loss
statement and see how you're doing
that's a that requires a lot of wisdom
yeah and so I'm um more content than you
that the level of Entrepreneurship
that's in first right now in particular
in F FRC where gathering enough money to
be in the competition requires some very
serious thoughts about budgeting and
fundraising and making sure that you get
a lot of stuff done we're talking tens
of thousands of dollars of well I mean
and you if you have a big group that's
going to travel somewhere that's that's
tough yeah so it's it's a complicated
thing and I I think um being
careful
at pretending to be entrepreneurs yeah
you can learn a lot but if you really
want to learn it you do it yeah and if
kids are in fact trying to get ready for
college and stuff you want to be careful
about how far out of the mainstream you
lure them I understand that that can be
a wonderful experience but there's more
and more um it needs to be a more clear
option that's the thing it's not it's
less so potentially about yeah maybe
luring but more so just about it being
an option that this moonshot that you
have in your mind when you're in high
school can actually be prototyped and
executed and brought to the market when
you're 16 or 17 and you can become a
roaring entrepreneur at a young age and
you can learn potentially a lot more
than you could stuck in a classroom
because maybe that's the way that you
learn and just to make it more of an
option I would like to see a prize model
potentially at first um um where you do
propose some sort of a maybe $100,000
through through a sponsor challenge for
the um the students during the off seon
right now is the season from January
until April is the season and then um uh
the build season and then tournaments
and then that's for the first robotics
competition but then after that there's
new things that you've introduced into
the first curriculum but I think that if
potentially having a um a
a thousands of dollars in prizes for um
the offseason could be very interesting
crowdsourcing ideas that are solving
some pressing challenges similar to The
X prise model um that exists and I think
that could um potentially Spur off a lot
of Entrepreneurship we'll see we'll see
um okay quick um and you yourself also
ended up um doing some entrepreneurship
with Med Miner and um Med I was an
adviser to Med Miner but I I've been
involved in several you know myo was uh
started by a couple of former students
and
uh medminder is Med is doing quite well
it's really really very nice and um and
that's for in that's sort of for this
process of uh of reminding um uh uh the
it's like enhancing the the called the
adherence process to taking a
medications as needed and sending
reminders for forgotten and um and
sending for the caretakers as well
sending reminders and that's a wonderful
um example of the complexity of
Entrepreneurship U Iran I the founder of
medminder um worked with some other
students at Sloan and they' come up with
a pill box that would help people that
were having trouble remembering to take
their pills and he discovered in the
process that I had given that problem to
product design class in engineering some
years before see and uh do it because my
mother had Alzheimer's and she was in
Louisiana and I tried all these ways
this is before the web was around but I
tried all these ways to help her
remember to take her pills and mother
would beat the system in order to make
sure that I was comfortable that she was
doing it so she would go back and fix
the stuff to make it look like she was
doing it right so she she would cheat to
try to keep me happy y but it's very
clear that you know lack of adherence to
medical stuff is a huge huge cost it's a
big deal so the device is really a
wonderful project to work on but it's
not the right business model so medm
minder is doing quite well now because
it is a pharmacy and the device is free
if you use the pharmacy so what people
want is so hard to know in advance you
know I I have enormous respect for what
it's like to try to see all the way
through to the customer exactly to and
we we mails hard don't listen so one of
the reason we want more women in
technology is because their their
empathy is much more upfront and they're
more likely to listen to the customer
and I believe that empathy leads to good
products and ethical Behavior so yes yes
my my ethics are empathy based yes yes
taking the perspective of one of
anothers there's there's a lot that goes
into that with um ethical there's a lot
of ethical quandries going on so let's
let's talk about those um they're we're
approaching the age of exponential
Technologies U we were talking earlier
about automation being in involved in so
many different of Industries and these
exponentials are causing a lot of of
they they're stirring up the the work
economy in very interesting ways and we
have to adapt and change to not um leave
people behind and help and help them
move forward so talk to us about you you
know your thoughts on the future of work
and what's going on with the exponential
Technologies and ethical quandries
associated with some of this
well I recently U published an oped
piece in the MIT faculty newsletter
entitled um on nerd epistemology and
critical thinking I think that was the
title I
believe
that people who understand the laws of
the
universe
and understand themselves and how you
fit in
society um will be better equipped to
try to deal with some of the really
complex and pressing things that are
going on you Christoper is a big deal
yeah as far as I can tell
um I suggested in that
oped that what nerd epistemology to me
is allegiance to objective truth as we
know it yeah
and
recently um Frank Gman a first supporter
and wonderful man gave
me a glass ball glass sphere about that
big that is a super small model of the
universe oh it so cool I mean and so
there tiny tiny tiny spots in it that if
you just kind of scretch you can barely
see and they look it looks a bit cloudy
because of those tiny spots it's a model
of the
Universe I think it's I call it my human
humility
model because if you imagine that that's
the universe and you were try to find
our
galaxy it's really hard yeah wow any of
you could find our galaxy what are the
chances you can find our solar system
and if you find our solar system what
are the chances you find our planet Etc
despite
that and despite the fact that we've
known that stuff that that's the way it
is for quite a long time most humans
still believe that we are the center of
the universe and that's just that's just
objectively not true so one of the
things I think we need to do is learn
enough about the Universe to develop
some humility about us and yes one of
the reasons that I I really appreciated
uh Margaret and I recently finished
reading yal Noah Harari sapiens because
it's kind of an objective look at our
species one of the best books ever
written in my opinion yeah that's it's a
it's
palpably a seric in places and you know
we
need to think more carefully about our
place
now that perspective is
daunting in fact when I was a graduate
student one of my dear friends and I
stayed up drinking beer all night to
Define good and we we really it was hard
you know and we drank beer and talked
all night and at the end of the night we
decided that the definition of good is a
function only of time to
re-election and that's been robust for
years so what one does
about education in the United States or
the world situation now is different if
you were the philosopher king of the
universe you might first wipe out planet
Earth and start something else somewhere
else you know just the time period
matters yeah so
good is complic
at and we're probably obligated to base
our our seeking good on empathy because
that's a uniquely human thing the the
universe that I just talked about is is
really big and it's
perfect it mother nature does exactly
the same thing all the time you know no
matter what humans think the universe is
doing its thing so
that's
great uh I like how you couple together
the UN understanding the universe and I
like thinking about it like big history
evolution of Cosmos life and humanity
and then I like how you coupled that
with understanding yourself and
understanding how you can be your
maximum potential in the world and then
when you combine those two things
together with a deep sense of empathy
that we are a Unity here on Earth as
this evolution of conscious than
goodness now from here where do we go
next and how do we work together well
and and that's you know like the
universe is bumping along and what we
think's not going to change yet but we
have empathy and love and creativity and
Leadership and you know and we humans
have looked over there at the universe
and said wow I understand that it's
amazing I can I can use that to predict
I can do things with that I can help
other humans Stay Alive by understanding
How the Universe works and and that that
stuff is the uniquely human
stuff is how we can add value and so
thinking carefully about how that works
you know
the
when the Chinese just sent a rocket and
landed a Rover on the other side of the
moon the Chinese scientists that
designed that rocket didn't have a vague
idea about the mechanics of of travel of
Newton's laws and thermodynamics for the
rocket etc etc they had it right yes and
you know the European Union sent
um a a a device that found a comet and
you know it after 14
years the guys were sitting there
listening and it said hey I'm awake they
said wow it's out there and he said you
know that Comet you sent me to see I see
it I want see a picture of it yeah yeah
yeah I mean and and I I caught up with
it here here's this little thing we'll
put it down on the comet you know that's
amazing so humans humans have taken this
thing that we use and developed great
Insight
but this thing that we use
came to us through
Evolution and it's got some bad stuff in
it the stuff that still you know was
obviously
rape propagated the DNA of
some um ancient
beings empathetic love and sexual
violence are on opposite ends of a
attraction to other humans scale the
only tool we got to sort out which one
of those we're going to do is our
intellect tribalism look at tribalism
man tribalism is very heavy it's there
because when you were out in the
savannah and you agreed with your tribe
members and you had allegiance to your
tribe members your DNA
survived if you were some weird dude
that thought about Truth uh maybe you
didn't so we still have an incredibly
powerful buil-in
inclination to do things that others
around us are doing and you know if you
look at religion it's Geographic you
know if you look at a whole bunch of
belief structures they have to do with
who you're with rather than what you
really so and could we ex could we
expand our Circle our community for
Earth to the whole entity that is our
planet and uh caring about each other in
that in that sense and I think we we
we're on our well on our way uh and I
think it will solve some of these
pressing ethical quandaries that we have
but we got to actually care about
uplifting and democratizing all at the
same time and increasing economic
degrees of freedom and we got to make
sure that that's not going to happen
unless each of us regards those others
as something other than those others yes
correct as humans as Humanity yeah
correct as our fellow brothers and
sisters on the planet um but we also
have to put our own oxygen mask on first
as well and that's a big thing that we
see around us today um we we got to we
got to take ourselves potentially away
from dependency and more towards um well
more towards making sure that we
ourselves are able to figure out our our
own Pro anyway there's so much there's
so much to unpack there Woody I want to
I want to go um a couple quick things on
the way out I always ask um these
questions so um this has been super wide
ranging and interesting um and I want to
make sure that I touch on this this is
one that I normally don't ask but I want
to ask you
specifically um what are you most
looking forward to in mechanical
engineering
um well clarify that just a little bit I
don't want to ask you to over Define the
question but
um you mean what about my profession
would be a wonderful
thing aspirationally yeah what what do
you see in the future of mechanical
engineering as that that you're most
excited about oh
okay that's somewhat different but let
me
mix cool uh
[Music]
answers I would like to see graci's
professionalism become part of the ethos
of becoming a mechanical
engineer I'm not saying that it is not
but I do think it's fair to say that
it's not given the attention that it
should
and I'm somewhat frustrated that I'm I'm
proud to be a member of the National
Academy of
engineering but we National Academy
members the academy was created to
advise
Congress we're not very effective that I
mean the system did not come to the
National Academy and say
write a report which talks about the
likely effectiveness of various means of
controlling the southern border or
whatever I mean we're not in the
Forefront U the academy has
written many reports on climate
change Congress is not paying
attention most of the government's not
paying attention to what we're doing as
we gain more scientists and engineers in
Congress I think will have big change
yeah and
we
what I think it's necessary if that's
going to happen that part of the
profession of mechanical engineering
must include I'm going to
help change society in positive ways and
if it means that I have to run for
office do it but be part of the decision
process uh we democracy is wonderful
but when we're being governed by people
that are not interested in understanding
that's kind of scary so we need to get
yeah people that are willing to think to
be more influential in that process so
that we make reasonable
decision um Jeff BOS was the U Honore at
the first Gaya in New York recently and
he said several things that were just
really um wonderfully insightful he
talked about decision process seas and
you know if there's a if there's a
decision that is revocable then do it
get on with it if there's one that you
can never change irrevocable get all the
data you can and only go to your gut if
you after you've saturated all the
understanding it's a good way to put it
yeah we we need to do that sort of stuff
more and the nerd epistemology part
of how we
think needs to move up you know Society
still kind of giggles at
nerds um but you know when I look out
the window of an
airplane and I can guess what most of
those things out there are based on some
understanding of fluid mechanics and
stuff that's really satisfying that's
nice totally so being a immersed in
something that you can sort of
understand is a big deal yes yes it's
it's the it's so interesting that that
you say that um because I'm currently at
Dan Brown's Meditation Retreat here in
Boston and I'm sitting in the room and
I'm looking at the light and I'm
thinking about the constant stream of
photons being emitted from the light and
then I'm looking at the speakers that
were Dan's voice as being propagated out
of and I'm thinking about the sound
waves coming from that I'm looking at
the wood floor I'm thinking about the
trees that were cut and put in the wood
I'm thinking about the cotton in the
cushions that we're sitting on and how
that grew and so when you look at the
the the ve when you look at vehicles and
buildings and and all different types of
tools that that exist and you and you
have a a pretty good if not completely
understanding of how they work it in abl
it brings you closer to the truth and
further away from the Black Box
mentality and you also brought the Jeff
bez's understanding of how things are if
if you got to gather as much data as
possible about something like uh about
the way that humanity is making a a
decision about artificial intelligence
or about climate science or
about because there's only there's only
one time to to to potentially uh
irrevocable we need to get it right now
yeah get it right the first time so does
did Origins summarize Dan Brown's
philosophy you know Origins yeah of well
the book origin oh the book origins or
origin how origin origin origin um um
that's a good question I'm not sure yeah
I do I do know that I'm starting to know
that that that
Awakening to
the profound sense of
unity is so gorgeous the the the feeling
of Love uh and Oneness being everywhere
all the time and just us not fully
tapping into it because we haven't train
that muscle enough have you do you
meditate have you ever experienced
Oneness
um I I I I believe I have because I've
been I've been doing this for couple
years now um almost 3 years and and um
and I would say that there are different
ways up the mountain as is usually said
um but when you start getting closer to
a profound that profound feeling and um
it's just it's just um there's nothing
quite like it and then you kind of
you're you're you you you
compassionately melt into how grateful
you are for for life and for each other
and there's nothing quite like it it'd
be cool to see more meditation in first
robotics um and with engineers and
scientists in general um and also in
Congress and the United Nations and yeah
so have you uh Michael Poland's new
description of the path up the mountain
is really interesting so did you know
that you had a default mode Network
before that book uh yeah I didn't I had
never heard of it yeah and I think his
insight
about the link between psychedelic drugs
and Oneness is really interesting it's
very profound and
it's there's also different ways up the
Psychedelic Mountain um with different
psychedelics and there's different
dosages of the psychedelics um but the
uh dissolving of the default mode
Network the interplay of different
neural circuitry that enables you to
potentially be more creative and uh
potentially see the world in new and
interesting ways of that Oneness is all
very cool and I think that playing along
with some meditation and um it and it
it's just would he it's just very
difficult to to get to the point of of
Oneness because I think there's there is
a um how can I explain there is uh
optimists think about Oneness MH uh
pessimists think about a Perpetual state
of of of we'll never get
along and then
realists understand I think
that there's a hard path to get to
Oneness and it's going to require
because Earth is a complex system of 7.7
billion humans all trying to engage with
each other and so we got to figure out
how to work together to get to that
point want it so I think optimists want
it tomorrow pessimists think we'll never
get it and realists say it's a
complicated path and we got to figure
out how to get there so um what the
couplee questions way out um spending a
lot of time in computation uh I'm sure
that you've can you've used simulations
before the show's called simulation we
love asking people about the about do
you think this is a simulation that this
is a simulation yeah
um uh let's
see
I think probably
not
um
but vs ramachandran in in the book uh
Phantoms in the brain his last
chapter argues that Consciousness is
nothing more or less than your model of
what's out
there I think that's probably right
so this is not a
simulation but you
are cuz you know my default mode network
has said Woody you're separate than
Allen and you're not part of that flat
file um and I have a model of what's out
there and when I die that simulation is
going to shut
down
um I think that's probably reasonable
cuz I can't
know anything about you being there
unless if I touch you and I get some
feedback that that haptic agreed with my
model yeah yeah the downside given what
we're discussing is that if my default
mode network over constrains me to stay
within my model or stay to make sure
that the model of what's out there is
not too expansive if it exercises
confirmation bias for what it you know I
I like to hear things that I already
think I believe then I may not get to
learn as much
so yes it part of this is a
simulation and both of us need to learn
how to modulate the degree to which we
can test new things in that simulation
we can tweak the dials yes yes tweak the
variables in the simulation yep yep and
uh figure out how to maximize our our
character's potential in the in the in
the in the game that we're that we're
leveling up in um I I that's that's a
really great way to to to to put it is
that um that this is um that your what
you're running in your mind is uh and
the the the wisdoms that you have pass
them along before the simulation of you
ends and that's that's actually the
reason why this collective learning and
knowledge of humanity that's why we're
here because of the collective we're
able to build on top um quite quickly on
the shoulders of giants on the shoulders
of giant us right last
question what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world most
beautiful thing in the
world uh probably the concept of
beauty
so
and I don't understand
it um and you know it's
Evolution gave us this kind of fun thing
thing you know the
um the positive part of awe is a big
deal and I really really feel sorry for
people that don't seek a yeah um like
you know my going to the do the zero g
flight next month is because I want to
be in awe of what it's like to be
weightless seeking um so my wife and I
are amateur nature photographers and we
love photographing beautiful birds yes
but the most beautiful thing is
that why does that beautiful thing give
me pleasure or awe or whatever that's
about so whatever that uh process is is
probably the most beautiful thing
interesting so our relationship with awe
and why we find things beautiful is the
most beautiful thing very very
interesting yeah it's it almost seems as
though Earth has
in the universe has in a sense made
these things so just like beautiful for
us to to to awe to get gawk at and be
inspired by and um yeah and in some
cases you know rather than say that God
has a sense of humor it seems like
Evolution has a sense of humor totally
yeah and what's the difference between
yeah yeah yeah exactly um Woody what a
pleasure this has been thank you so much
for coming on to the show nice to have
you here yes it's been such a pleasure
being at MIT in your office um and
learning from you um just scratching the
surface we have so much more to
understand about U mechanical
engineering what's went into your life
and what's went into this process of of
of of inspiring thousands and now you
know hundreds of thousands millions of
kids now around the world um to become
leaders uh in building the future thank
you for that and I hope I hope your
audience gets just a little bit infected
with nerd epistemology yeah yeah exactly
yes yes it's it's so crucial and um and
we'll we'll um thank you thank you
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it and as Woody said get
infected with the spirit of wanting to
build up this objective truth in reality
and to manifest your destiny and your
dreams into the world build the future
everyone give us your thoughts in the
comments below uh let's build a little
Community around some of the things that
we talked about in this episode much
love to you all and we will see you
soon the Woody flow I love it the Woody
flowers thumbs up it's so good